you don't normally see images like these
or indeed numbers like these they are
unprecedented nearly 1200 men women and
children reach the UK in a single day by
crossing the channel and this facility
stretched as it is is where they are
initially taken to but this is
effectively the front line where the
authorities begin the whole process of
dealing with the migrants and processing
them the sheer scale of the operation
here the Manpower we've seen the
resources needed it's quite
extraordinary
many people here ask what the french
authorities are doing to stop the
crossings they say they prevented seven
small boats and 99 people from getting
to Britain but 33 dinghies still got
through the home office insists it's
working with its French counterparts to
reduce that number to zero what country
did you come from yeah Iran the prime
minister is adamant it's the French who
must do more
we have a problem which is that they're
coming from France and in the end if the
French authorities will not or cannot
control those departures it's very
difficult for us to to turn them back at
Sea we want to do that we want to do
that in a safe and a humane way but it's
very difficult groups that campaign from
migrant welfare say the situation here
is now so bad that the government should
completely change its strategy well we
think the government needs to do a
complete about turn on this 180 degree
turn we've spent a huge amount of public
money
chaos none of it is working and we would
suggest that we could issue humanitarian
visas to people that want to come and
claim asylum in the UK that would kill
the traffickers business overnight this
facility has doubled in size in the past
week and a new one has been open to deal
with the influx stormy seas and poor
weather will stop the people traffickers
for the coming days but the authorities
know that as soon as the channel is calm
again more migrants will attempt to
cross it and the Brady Sky News in Dover